Zoe Parham: There is a message that has
gone out to everyone abroad,
I think it's from the state
department, that says,
"Come home now, or you might
not be able to come home."
That message came out after we were stuck.
After we were stuck in Peru.
I bought a United flight
that was going to go from
Lima to Houston to Denver.
I had my boyfriend call United
just to confirm everything,
and my flight had been canceled,
and I was never notified.
And that's when I started
to feel like, that's weird,
you know, the quarantine
is supposed to be over.
Like, why don't I have a flight anymore?
Arturo Salgado: When we came,
India only had three cases,
and right now they have over 500.
Literally, from one day to the next,
everything just changed.
When we got to Mumbai, it was like:
"OK, we're closing everything down.
There are no more flights."
Brian Johnson: I've already been rebooked
eight to 10 times since last Tuesday.
If I didn't have a wife and
kids to get back home to,
I think I would've just stayed
in Austria and just given up.
Parham: United won't be
flying back until May.
I've heard the same thing about American.
Things are not just returning to normal
when the quarantine is over.
And there've been a lot of rumors
that the quarantine is
just going to be extended.
Johnson: In Austria they said,
"OK, what we're gonna do
is shut down nonessential shops."
And I'm thinking that's
not too big of a deal.
The next day or two, all
the restaurants shut down.
I have no kitchenette.
I couldn't even find a
supermarket that was open.
I didn't really know what I was gonna do.
Salgado: The curfew here in India has been
extended until April 14.
That means there are no buses, no flights.
No means of transportation anywhere.
Elizabeth Lord: These
restrictions have been put
in rapid fire without a lot of recourse
for people that are on the road.
Some people were on camping trips
or in northern districts,
which takes either a domestic flight,
which are also suspended,
or many, many hours of
travel by the roads.
Salgado: They just made
an announcement today
that all foreigners that
arrived after February 15
have to stay inside.
So that's making it a little
difficult for us to buy food.
Parham: A lot of people
have made comments like,
"Wow, what a nice place to be stuck."
And I disagree.
This quarantine is
enforced by martial law.
You can only leave your home
between 5 a.m. and 8 p.m.,
and it's only to go to a bank,
pharmacy, or grocery store. That's it.
We step outside to go
to the grocery store,
and we have to talk to police
and tell them where we're going.
Johnson: I stay in this small
little hotel when I'm there,
'cause it's a great location,
right in the center of Vienna.
The weird thing is that the streets
and everything are so empty. So empty.
They don't play around.
But if they catch you
doing something obvious,
like shaking hands or
hugging, you will get fined.
And I heard it was, like,
as much as 600 euros.
Salgado: There are a lot of hotels here
and hostels that are not
taking any foreigners.
Lord: There was an
article in the India Times
about a guesthouse owner
being booked and arrested
for having accepted foreigners.
That story alone can create a lot of fear
for people in a position to take us in.
Salgado: We were very lucky to find
a hostel here in Bandra in Mumbai.
Lord: So, right now we're
obeying the lockdown.
We haven't left our hotel,
which is a nice hotel that we called ahead
and said that they would accept us.
But we're gonna be
running out of funds soon.
They're not providing any meals.
We don't have any choice but to pay
the hotel restaurant for all of our food.
Grocery shopping is, in theory, available.
But with the stories that I've heard
about foreigners, you
know, being threatened
with violence, we don't feel as though
we can leave just to get basic supplies.
Salgado: We were trying
to buy food yesterday,
and people did not want
to sell us anything
because we were foreigners.
They simply said: "Go away.
We are closed for the night.
We're closed for the day."
It's been a little difficult.
We came across discrimination, even.
Just two days ago we were walking
in the street, looking for food,
and people started yelling
"corona" at me and my friend.
Johnson: So, at the point I said, OK,
it's time to reach out to the embassy.
The reply, and I kid you not,
was one sentence that said,
"If you're having problems
finding a flight back,
well, we recommend that you try Expedia
or Google Flights to find an alternate."
That was the US Embassy's reply to me.
Lord: Our first call to the US Embassy
was on Saturday the 21st.
They highly recommended that
we get out before the 22nd,
which at that point was 12 hours away,
which was when the suspension
of the international
flights was happening.
And we had just been
able to secure our entry
into Delhi and to get to a hotel,
so the traveling that we were
doing on land was difficult,
and we weren't able to make that happen.
Parham: The US Embassy hasn't really
gotten back to our situation directly.
I've emailed them so many times,
and it says to only email them once
and wait for a response,
but when I finally do get responses,
they're just automated.
I do not want to be forgotten here.
Lord: It's very difficult for someone
that has never had dealings
with the US Embassy
not to know what you can
ask, like repatriation loans.
I didn't know that that was a thing
until, you know, two days later.
Salgado: We're thinking,
is it gonna be a week,
two weeks, a month, two months?
That's what's stressing us out right now.
Lord: We might be here
for the full 21 days,
and then maybe be hoping
that it's only 21 days.
And then, you know, I would have to do
what the embassy suggested, which is start
sourcing funds from
friends and family at home.
Parham: I'm hoping that the US Embassy
can organize a car for us
with the proper documentation
and at least get us to Lima.
So we're available for when our names
do come up on the chartered flights.
Salgado: We're willing to do anything
to get back home at this point.
Whether it's paying for a flight,
travel for two days if
necessary. Anything.
We just want to get back
home to our families.
Parham: In a time that's filled
with so much uncertainty,
you just want to be close to your family.